Hello everyone, and welcome
to a two-part lecture
series on laboratory
medicine and anemias. My name
is Noah Chernick, and
before we get started with
the lectures, I want to
quickly thank Dr. Saggio for
all of his guidance in
developing these lectures.
I'm available to address
any questions, concerns,
or comments that you
may have in regards to
this lecture or anything
anemia-related. Please
reach out if you want
to meet one-on-one or
in a group setting. either
are completely fine.
Here are our learning
objectives for today's
lecture, both for
part 1 and for part 2.
And for our lecture
layout today, part 1
will again just dive
into the general
concepts of anemia
and microcytic anemia.
Part 2 will deal with the
normocytic and
macrocytic anemias.
So before we discuss
specific microcytic
anemias, I want to
quickly talk about some
of the the basics of
underlying anemias.
So, very simply, anemia
is a significant deficit
or decrease in the mass
of circulating red blood
cells. But why do we
care about this decrease?
Red blood cells, as
most of you should know,
transport oxygen to cells
and tissues. If we have a
decrease of the function
or number of red blood
cells, we have a decreased
capacity to carry and
deliver oxygen and just
carry out everyday life.
So, the main players
with anemia are
known as erythrocytes,
red blood cells.
Their function, again,
is to carry oxygen and
carbon dioxide to the
peripheral vasculature and
then bring CO2 back to
the lungs for exchange.
Their shape is biconcave,
meaning that they have
a very nice middle area
that is kind of flattened
and lower than the
rest of the blood cell.
They're also anucleate
cells, and they really don't
have any organelles within
the cell. This is all in an
effort to increase the amount
of cytoplasm in the cell.
The more cytoplasm
we have, the more
hemoglobin, and the
more oxygen-carrying
capacity each red
blood cell will have.
These cells are also
extremely flexible, which is
really important when
you consider they have to
navigate very small
capillaries in the peripheral
vasculature. And this
flexibility is actually due
to special membrane
proteins, and we'll learn a
little bit more about this
in the following lecture.
And their lifespan
is about 120 days.
Even in healthy individuals,
you usually see about
1% of all red blood cells
turn over each and every
day. And they're simply
removed because they're old.
So I want to talk a little
bit more about the life cycle
of a red blood cell. Red
blood cells are produced in
the bone marrow via a process
called erythropoiesis.
Erythropoietin growth
factor, also known as
EPO or EPO, helps
stimulate this process.
The interstitial cells
in the peritubular
capillary of the renal
cortex sense a decrease in
O2 and actually secrete
the erythropoietin.
This EPO then signals
to the bone marrow to
actually start generating
new red blood cells.
And just a little fact,
for your knowledge,
erythropoietin and
hematocrit, which essentially
is the percentage of red
blood cells that comprise
your entire serum, are
inversely proportional.
Reticulocytes are very, very
important in this
entire process.
These are also known as
immature red blood cells
that are released into
circulation from the
bone marrow. And in about
24 to 48 hours from their
release, they will mature
into full red blood
cells. This reticulocyte
count in any normal
individual is usually
around one to two percent.
And on visualization
with the peripheral blood
smear, these reticulocytes
appear more basophilic,
also known as a purplish
color, compared to
mature red blood cells.
And this is due to
ribosomal RNA still being
present in these cells.
And finally, once these
reticulocytes mature and they
go through about 120 days
of normal function as red
blood cells, these senescent
or now old red blood cells
are removed by macrophages
in the spleen, liver, and
bone marrow, and this
system is known as the
reticuloendothelial system that
recycles the red blood cells.
Generally, we can break
anemia down into three
separate types of anemias.
All of these categories are
fairly intuitive with the
pathophysiology behind
them. The first one is simply
blood loss. We're losing
more blood than we're able
to produce. Our production
is not affected, but
we're simply losing more
blood than the body can
maintain via new production.
The second category is
actual decrease in red
blood cell production.
We have an issue with
erythropoiesis. The body
cannot produce enough red
blood cells to keep up
with the destruction, and
we usually see a decreased
reticulocyte count.
The bone marrow is not
responding properly to
this new sense of anemia.
And finally, you could
see almost the opposite
of decreased production,
which is increased
destruction, also known as
hemolysis. And this
is more destruction of
red blood cells than
we actually can create.
And usually we'll see
splenomegaly and jaundice
due to increased red
blood cell breakdown.
So the clinical presentation
of anemia, there are
vast signs and symptoms
that will usually vary with
the underlying etologies.
But all of these signs
and symptoms can kind
of be pushed back to one
underlying reason. And that's
essentially the resulting
tissue hypoxia due to
the decrease O2. And some
of these symptoms can
include weakness, fatigue,
malaise, dyspnea on
mild exertion, some big
buzzwords and things that
you may more commonly see in
clinic are pallor, especially
in the conjunctiva.
You may see pale
skin. You could
see something
called spoon nails,
dizziness, headache, faintness,
cardiac issues, cardiac
failure in some severe
cases. and there are a
few specific anemias that
may have specific
underlying pathologies,
such as sickle cell
disease, along with sickle
cell pain crisis, and
potentially renal failure.
However, in general,
these symptoms
are broad and don't
necessarily correlate
with the severity
of the anemia.
Essentially, what that
means is some individual
may present with a very
severe anemia, but their
symptoms may not present
similarly. They may just
say, yeah, I feel tired
from time to time. then
you look at their hemoglobin
levels and it's 7.2.
So there are a few
measurements for anemia and
the first ones we
actually will look at are
on every single CBC or
complete blood count.
So these three values
are your red blood cell
count, your hemoglobin,
and your hematocrit.
And there's actually a
rule of three if we look at
these three values. For
normal, each of them should
be 5, 15, and 45 respectfully.
So if you multiply
the red blood cell count by
3, you get the hemoglobin.
Multiply hemoglobin by
3, you get hematocrit.
And just as a clinical
pearl, this isn't necessarily
something that is important
for your education
right now, but it will be
in two years when you're
in the wards on rotations,
is that one unit of
packed red blood cells will
increase your hemoglobin
by 1 and your hematocrit
by 3. And again, we see
this rule of 3 being in
play here. 1 times 3 is 3.
Additionally, just
to kind of continue
to talk about
these measurements,
the red blood cell count
is the actual number of red
blood cells in the blood.
The hemoglobin is the
concentration of hemoglobin
in the blood, and it actually
reflects a red blood cell's
ability to carry oxygen.
And finally, hematocrit
measures the percentage
of erythrocyte volume
in the blood sample.
This essentially shows
what percentage of the
entire whole blood is
actually red blood cells.
And importantly, in
patients with anemia, they
typically have low hemoglobin
and hematocrit, and
you should also see low
red blood cell counts.
So, hemoglobin. You've heard
me reference it a couple
times, but let's actually
describe what it is. Hemoglobin
is the oxygen-carrying
aspect of the red blood
cell. It's almost the star of
the show without hemoglobin
red blood cells are fairly
useless and it's composed
of two very self-explanatory
parts heme which is actually
made up of iron and
protoporphyrin and then globin
which are protein chains
typically in a normal hemoglobin
which is hba you will
have two alpha chains and
then two beta chains and as
you can see here the heme
is actually comprised of
protoporphyrin and then iron.
So there are additional
measurements that we can use
to help identify specific
anemias and then also start
to classify them. The
first value in a very very
key one is something called
mean cell volume, which is
essentially the average
size of the red blood cell.
Another key value that
kind of goes hand-in-hand
with the size of the red
blood cell is the red
blood cell distribution
width. And this actually
measures the variability
of the MCV. And what that
means is it looks at all
the red blood cells in
a CBC and sees what the
range of sizes is. So if
all the cells are a
similar size, then they'll
have a low variation, low
variance, and a low RDW.
However, if we have
cells of many different
sizes, some are big,
some red blood cells are
small, some red blood
cells or normal size,
we will see a higher
RDW because we have a
larger range or larger
variance in the size.
To measure the actual
amount of hemoglobin per red
blood cell, we can look at two
values, the mean corpuscular
hemoglobin, which is the
amount of hemoglobin in
an average erythrocyte,
and the mean corpuscular
hemoglobin concentration, which
provides the percentage of
hemoglobin concentration
in an average erythrocyte.
And finally, something
you've already heard me
reference once or twice is
the reticulocyte count, which
is the percentage of total
red blood cells that are
reticulocytes. This is really
important in determining
when we see an anemia
if the underlying cause
could be the bone marrow
or if the bone marrow is
responding appropriately to
the anemia. And what I mean
by that is that when we
have an anemia and the bone
marrow is signaled from
erythropoietin to start
generating more red blood
cells, you would expect to see
more reticulocytes or a
higher reticulocyte count.
And if we see this increased
reticulocyte count,
we know the marrow is
responding appropriately.
It recognizes the anemia
and is trying to push
more red blood cells out
to correct for it. If we
have an anemia without this
increase in reticulocyte
count, it actually
could point to the bone
marrow being the underlying
issue for the anemia.
But just one little caveat
with this, remember that
like most other things in
the body there can be a
delay so the bone marrow
takes some time to respond
so after we do some of our
lab tests we can actually
now look and visualize the
red blood cells themselves
and it's a follow-up
test that we could do for
an abnormal cpc and it's
called a peripheral blood
smear and this is where we
actually visually inspect
the red blood cells for
their shape and their color
and you use a special
stain in this peripheral
blood smear and it's known
as the right gasmus stain.
When we examine a normal
peripheral blood smear,
you want to notice a few
different things, and the
most important being this
almost central area of
pallor that you can see.
And this is actually due
to the biconcave disc shape
of the red blood cell.
What I mean by that is,
if you can remember, that
red blood cell almost has
a, and I'm going to take out
my pen, my apologies for
my poor drawing skills,
have a kind of disc shape in
the cell, and it's actually
in this middle piece,
you have less cytoplasm,
right? We just have less
volume in this middle area.
Because we have less
cytoplasm in this
middle area, you
have less hemoglobin.
Hemoglobin is actually
responsible for the coloring of
the red blood cell. So, if
we have less coloring, we
have less hemoglobin in this
middle area, it won't appear
as red compared to the
outer portions, maybe here
or here, that have more
hemoglobin. So I know that's a
little bit of a complex or
long explanation, but it will
kind of come into play
later on when we learn about
some abnormal shapes of red
blood cells. So again, just
remember, the reason why
we kind of see the central
area of pallor is because
there's actual decrease in
hemoglobin because of this
kind of biconcave disc shape.
So we've talked about
a couple different lab
values. We could talk about
how we visualize the red
blood cells under certain
peripheral blood smears
and what they look like
and the reasons why.
But we actually want to
get into classifications
and recognition of certain
anemias. So the first thing
you will do when someone
comes in with a potential
anemia, right, they come in
with fatigue conjunctival
pallor maybe they're
becoming exerted or very
tired with just walking
the first test you should
be ordering is a cbc if your
hemoglobin your hematocrit
and or your red blood
cell count is low by
definition your patient is
anemic but we can't stop
there we actually have to
determine the type of anemia
the patient may have and
more importantly, understand
and figure out the
underlying pathology behind
the anemia. The next best
step you should take in
kind of making this analysis
is looking at the MCV.
This MCV actually breaks down
anemias into three separate
types, all based off of
the average size. So we
have a microcytic, or smaller
red blood cells, with an
MCV of under 80, a normocytic,
which is an MCV of 80
to 100. Again, these are
normal size red blood cells.
And finally, we have
a macrocytic, which
is a large or MCV
greater than 100.
This slide just represents
some of the different
anemias broken down
into their microcytic,
normocytic, and macrocytic.
And these are all things
we will be discussing
over the next two videos.
So for the rest of this
first part of this two-part
series we'll be discussing the
microcytic anemias remember
all of these are an mcv
under 80 meaning these red
blood cells are smaller
than normal there are five
different types of microcytic
anemia that we will be
discussing in the rest of
this lecture and they are the
following iron deficiency
anemia anemia of chronic disease
lead poisoning cytoblastic
anemia and thalassemias.
In general, for all
microcytic anemias, your
red blood cells are
smaller than normal.
For iron deficiency anemia
and anemia of chronic
disease, please note
that these two anemias
are actually microcytic
only in the later
stages. They start out
as normocytic anemias.
And because of this
reason, you actually have a
mix of normal and smaller
red blood cell sizes.
Because we have this
increase in variance between
the normal and smaller
sizes, you're actually
going to see a higher
RDW in these two anemias.
So the actual reason for
microcytic anemias being
microcytic have to do with
red blood cell divisions
and a decrease in the
production of hemoglobin.
Erythroblasts, also known
as the red blood cell
progenitors in the bone
marrow, like to keep a certain
ratio of hemoglobin to
cytoplasm. As the red blood cell
divides, as you can see
on the left of this image,
the amount of hemoglobin
is normal, and will go
through one or two cell
divisions before the erythroblast
is happy and can go
off into the peripheral
blood as a normal acidic
cell with a normal amount of
hemoglobin. However, if
we have a decreased amount
of hemoglobin compared
to the total amount of
cytoplasm as seen in
microcytic anemias, we actually
have to undergo further
cell divisions in order to
achieve that same ratio of
hemoglobin to cytoplasm.
And again, microcytic anemias
in general, for all the
five we're going to discuss,
are due to a decrease
in the production of
hemoglobin. Somewhere along the
production, either from its
reactants, raw materials,
maybe some of the proteins
are not working properly,
hemoglobin cannot
be made properly.
And since we have
less hemoglobin, we
have to undergo
further cell divisions,
meaning we create
smaller cells.
And again, just to
reiterate, microcytic
anemias are at its basis
due to an issue with
creating hemoglobin. and
hemoglobin is responsible
for the pigmentation
in red blood cells.
Knowing this information,
we can kind of guess what
we should be seeing on a
peripheral blood smear.
Since we have less
hemoglobin, you'll have
hypopigmentation, and also
known as hypochromatic
red blood cells.
Under the microscope,
they'll appear paler due
to a lack of pigment.
And also due to a
decreased amount of
hemoglobin, the central
area of pallor will appear
larger. This, again,
goes back to that idea
of the biconcave disc,
that central region
has less cytoplasm
compared to the edges.
If we even decrease
the hemoglobin more,
because we can't produce
it, you're going to
see less pigmentation
in that central area.
So, what are the labs for
microcytic anemia? We go
through our CBC, we look at
our MCV, we realize, okay,
this is microcytic. What
should I do next? the next
best step for any lab
study is ordering an iron
study and the iron study
is very very important for
both your clinical practice
as well as an examination
purposes and I want to go
through each of these values
very quickly and talk
about them so it may be a
little bit easier for you
guys to understand the
results of these iron studies
as we go through each of
the five anemias in the
microcytic category just
remember that medicine has
a whole bunch of things that
you just have to brute force
memorize. This is actually
one that you can kind of
rationalize and not have
to commit to memory, but
it's only if you're able
to understand these values
and what they represent.
So let's start with
serum iron, and it simply
represents the amount of iron
in the blood. Very simple.
Serum ferritin represents
the storage of iron.
So it shows how much
iron is stored in the
bone marrow, macrophages,
and the liver.
And again, just
remember ferritin
is the protein
that stores iron.
So far, not too bad. Total
iron binding capacity
is one that may be a little
bit confusing via the
name, but when we actually
think about what it
is, it becomes a lot
easier. So it's actually the
amount of transferrin
circulating in the blood.
TIBC, in a nutshell,
you can just think of as
transferrin. And transferrin
is a protein that's
produced in the liver
and actually picks up the
iron from the GI system
and will transport it
throughout the plasma to
its final destination.
And there's actually a
little bit of a relationship
between iron storage, also
known as ferritin, and
TIBC. When the iron stores
in the bone marrow are
lower, you actually have
signals sent to the liver
to produce more transferrin.
So the bone marrow is
going to say to the liver,
hey, we need more iron,
and the liver in response
will produce more
transferrin, increasing our
total iron binding capacity.
And finally we have percent
saturation, which is
essentially just the percentage
of transferrin that is
bound to iron. So we could
see this increase with either
an increase in iron in
the serum or a decrease in
the transferrin amount,
right? This is simple math.
Ferritin and TIBC, as we
kind of already touched
upon, are usually opposite.
If we have increased
ferritin, it usually means
we have a lot of iron in
storage. So there's no need
to bring a lot more iron
from the plasma or the GI
system into the cells. So
our TIBC, also known as
transferrin, will be lower.
And it's actually the
opposite if we have low
iron stores. The bone
marrow will signal to
the liver that we need
more iron and in response
we will increase our
transferrin, therefore
increasing our total
iron binding capacity.
So our first
microcytic anemia is
going to be iron
deficiency anemia.
So in iron deficiency
anemia, it's fairly self
-explanatory, we have
a deficiency of iron.
And without iron, the
body cannot produce heme.
And iron deficiency anemia
is actually the most
common cause of anemia
worldwide, over 12% of
the world's population
according to up-to-date.
And very simply, we can
think of iron deficiency
as a formula where our
iron loss is greater
than our iron intake.
So we can either have
an increase in loss or
a decrease in intake.
And in general, iron
excretion from the body is not
very well regulated. So you
could have iron loss via
bleeding whether that's a
gi issue or cancer it also
could just be menses and
females and you also have
just general loss of epithelial
cells from the skin gut
and gu track and iron can
also be due to intake issues
right our ability to absorb
or ingest iron may be
decreased iron is absorbed
in the duodenum so any
issue in the duodenum can
actually affect the uptake you
also can have an adequate
nutritional supply of iron.
And in general, for
treatment of iron deficiency,
the first-line treatment is
just oral iron supplementation.
So, iron metabolism. This
is a very important slide,
and I know there seems
like there's a lot of text,
and the image seems scary
because it's a pathway,
and nobody likes looking
at chemical pathways. But I
promise, if you just
think about it, and we'll
highlight the important parts,
it won't be as daunting.
So first off, this
little mnemonic
in the top right
middle portion,
Iron Fist Bro,
actually shows the
different aspects of
the small intestine
where iron, folate,
and B12 are absorbed.
So iron in the body
is usually recycled in
general from circulated
and stored pools,
right, coming in and
out from ferritin.
In the blood, as we spoke
about, iron is carried as
transferrin. Transferrin
is a protein that's made
in the liver and essentially
all it's made to really
do is just deliver iron
to the cells that help
synthesize hemoglobin and
other important products. In
the GI system, iron has
to be consumed in either
meat or vegetable products.
In meat it's known as heme,
in vegetable it's known
as non-heme, and you see
iron absorbed by the
enterocytes within the duodenum.
For non-heme iron Fe3+, it
actually must be reduced
to Fe2+, by something
called ferireductase, also
known as cytochrome B, on
the surface of the enterocyte
in the duodenum. Once
it's reduced, it can then
be transported into the
cell by something called
DMT1. Heme is absorbed by
transporters in the enterocyte
themselves. And you
can look over here and
actually has a very nice
picture of this same process.
Once iron is absorbed into
the enterocyte, regardless
of if it's heme or non
-heme, it leaves via
the same protein, something
known as ferroportin.
Once it leaves the enterocyte
via ferroportin, it
is grabbed by transferrin
and then is transported
eventually to its final
destination, where it's stored
as ferritin. And this
whole process of absorbing
and bringing in iron from
the GI system is kind
of controlled by an acute
phase reactant known as
hepcidin, which helps
regulate this process by
decreasing ferroportin. So
if hepcidin is released,
you'll actually see a decrease
in absorption of iron.
So some takeaways from that
very long-winded slide.
Iron is absorbed in the
duodenum. Heme is absorbed better
than non-heme iron. Non
-heme iron just has to be
converted via a cytochrome
B and then absorbed by DMT1.
Once iron is finally
absorbed into the duodenal
enterocyte, it leaves
via ferroportin. In the
plasma, it's attached to
transferrin. In the cell,
it's attached to ferritin.
And then hepcidin is
one of these acute phase
reactants that regulates
this entire process by
decreasing ferroportin.
So let's talk about some
usual causes of iron
deficiency. A major one we
kind of talked about this
and probably is what
is happening and to our
friend over here from
Monty Python is something
called blood loss, right?
We're losing more iron and
we're losing more blood
than we could produce.
There also could be
things such as dietary
deficiencies, right?
Most iron comes from the
meat and vegetables that
we consume. If you have
nutritional insufficiencies
in your diet,
iron could be one of the
supplements affected.
If we break it down by
age, it becomes a little
bit more specific. So
in infants, human breast
milk is naturally low in
iron. So that's actually
the most common cause.
In children, most kids
are usually finicky. You
know, they eat chicken
finger and french fries
and that's about it.
My self was included
in that group.
It's usually poor diet.
Adults, 20 to 50 is a
little bit more segmented.
In males, you see the
most common cause being a
bleed, so peptic ulcer
disease, which is in the
upper GI tract, and in
females, it's actually split,
menorrhagia, which is an
increase of blood loss
with men's disease, or
pregnancy, which essentially
is just an increase in
overall iron demands.
In the elderly, it is again
split, but this time by
geographic location. In the
western world, you see more
causes such as colon polyps
and cancer, and in the
developing world it's
actually more hookworms. And a
little bit of a clinical
pearl for you guys, again not
necessarily super important
right now, but in the
future it can make you look
smart on rotations. Any elderly
individual with an iron
deficiency anemia, you have
to assume that they have
some form of colon polyp
or colon cancer until proven
otherwise. And the only
way that we can prove that
is usually via colonoscopy.
There are some
other causes to keep
in mind. Like we
said, malnutrition,
we get issues with
actual absorption, such
as, you know, celiac
disease, or surgeries.
Surgeries such as gastric
bypass surgery, where we
have food bypassing the
duodenum, or gastrectomy,
where the stomach acid
actually helps increase
Fe2. Those could also be
causes of iron deficiency.
and there are actually four
stages of iron deficiency
so the first stage is
the storage of iron is
depleted in the cells so we're
going to drop our ferritin
amounts right we're
draining the storage at the
same time the bone marrow
is going to go to the
liver and say hey we need
more iron please make more
transferrin to pick it
up from the GI system so
the cells are going to
recruit all the iron from the
plasma right they're going
to drain their own supplies
and then go into the
actual stores from the
plasma. Once the serum
iron is depleted, we'll see
some more values change.
We're going to see a decrease
in serum iron, a decrease
in percent saturation,
and our total iron binding
capacity is going to
continue to increase. We
can kind of rationalize
the reason for this
decrease in saturation
simply because the serum
iron is dropping and the
TIPC is increasing. If we
have a decreasing value
in the numerator, an
increasing value in the
denominator, we're going
to see the value drop.
The third stage is
actually normocytic anemia.
So early stage iron
deficiency is actually a
normocytic disease.
The body will begin to
make normal size red
blood cells, but they'll
reduce the quantity.
So the body kind of
goes into this quality
over quantity mindset.
We're going to see a decrease
in hemoglobin, hematocytic,
and red blood cells, and
the RDW at this point is
normal. And finally, you're
going to see a microcytic
hypochromic anemia in the
late stages. At this point,
the bone marrow is kind of
just throwing a prayer on
whatever type of iron it
can get. It's going to make
smaller red blood cells to
conserve that concentration
of hemoglobin, and we also
have fewer cells made.
And this is when we see our
MCV of under 80, and this
is also where we see our
RDW increase. And this is
because when you think about
it, these normocytic cells
in the early stages are
around for about four months.
So when we move to
a microcytic stage,
you're actually going to
increase the variation
of sizes of the red
blood cells. Some
will be normocytic,
some will be microcytic.
So our laboratory findings
for iron deficiency anemia.
Again, we're going to see
our MCV under 80 in the
later stages. This again is
a microcytic anemia. On our
peripheral blood smear,
we'll see microcytic and
hypochromic red blood cells.
There's going to be less
pigmentation due to less
hemoglobin, and we spoke about
this already. We're going
to see ferritin decrease,
right? The cells are going
to go through all of their
iron stores to try and
recruit more iron. The TIBC
is going to increase, and
this is because the liver is
going to produce more
transferrin in an attempt to
recruit more iron from the
GI system into the plasma
and eventually into the
cells. Our percent saturation
of transferrin will decrease
and again this is just
simple math. We decrease our
CRM iron, we increase our
TIBC, we're going to drop
that percent saturation.
Free erythrocyte
protoporphyrin, again
protoporphyrin combines
with iron to create heme. If
we lose iron but we can
make our protoporphyrin
fine, we're actually
going to have a backlog
of reactants, a backlog
of protoporphyrin.
And finally, RDW is
going to increase,
and this is again
due to the increased
mixings of sizes of
the red blood cells.
So, the clinical features
of iron deficiency, they
include our nonspecific
symptoms of anemia, such as
fatigue, malaise, dyspnea.
We also have some specific
symptoms, such as PICA, which
is the desire to eat non
-nutritive substances, such
as ice, clay, and dirt.
Coilinicchia, which is also
known as spoon nails, which
are these thin, concave nails
that may resemble spoons,
alopecia, which is hair
loss, angular chelitis,
which are lesions at the
corner of the mouth, but this,
again, is not necessarily
specific to iron deficiency.
You can see CNS symptoms,
such as restless leg syndrome,
and more kind of buzzwordy
ones, conjunctival
pallor, and finally, you can
see something called Plummer
-Vizin syndrome, which is
a triad of iron deficiency
anemia, esophageal webs,
and atrophic loussitis.
So our next microcytic
anemia that we are
going to discuss is
anemia of chronic disease.
So in anemia of chronic
disease, it's usually
associated with some
chronic inflammatory or
disease process, and it's
very common, actually
the most common in any
hospitalized patient.
the pathophysiology is
usually due to inflammatory
mediators such as interleukin
-6 being released in
inflammation or infection
type reactions and it will
limit the free iron via
an increase in hepcidin
production and remember we
talked about hepcidin a little
bit before it will block
ferroportin so decreasing
the amount of iron coming
in it also limits the
iron transfer from
macrophages to the erythroid
precursor cells and it also
suppresses EPO production.
And again, this is all a
response to inflammation,
which is usually,
and this response is
an evolutionary trait,
as bacteria need iron
for survival. The
bodies realize this and
actually is attempted to
limit bacterial growth.
And iron in response
is locked away
in the macrophages
of the bone marrow.
Your labs for anemia of
chronic disease will include
a decrease in TIPC because
our iron stores are really
high already. Ferritin
will be increased, and this
is because we're holding
on to more iron in the bone
marrow. Our percent saturation
will decrease because
we have less iron in
circulation, and our serum iron
is also going to be
decreased because the iron is
now sequestered in the bone.
We don't want it circulating
in the plasma because
that's where the bacteria
could potentially get it,
and the treatment is usually
to treat the underlying
disease or inflammation.
So anemia of chronic disease
and iron deficiency can
kind of present similarly
with their symptoms, and
it's actually a very big
question on exams, both
in-house and on your boards,
about how to differentiate
between these two on
iron studies. So again, I
want you guys to think
about the underlying
pathophysiology processes. If
we can think of iron deficiency
as just simply we don't
have enough iron, and
you understand how the body
will respond, it actually
becomes very easy. Then
you can think about anemia
of chronic disease, and
it's almost the opposite.
So, with that being said,
when we see iron deficiency
anemia, we're going to have
low iron stores, aka low
ferritin, and high total iron
binding capacity, or high
transferrin. In anemia of
chronic disease, we have
the opposite, right? We put
all of our iron in the bone
marrow. Because of that
we're going to decrease our
TIBC because we already have
enough iron in our stores.
And again please just don't
just memorize your lab
values. I know you have
a lot on your plate so if
you have the time to kind
of rationalize through
these values it really
helps a lot down the road.
Our next microcytic
anemia is going to be
citeroblastic anemia
and also lead poisoning.
So in citeroblastic anemia
we still have an issue with
heme synthesis but it's
no longer the issue with
iron right our iron which
you can see down here in this
nice picture of the pathway
is not an issue it's
actually now with the
protoporphyrin synthesis and heme
is actually generated in
both the mitochondria and the
cytoplasm this process goes
through both and through
this process there are
four specific enzymes and
reactions that are important
so the first one is amino
level unic acid synthetase
which converts succinyl-CoA
to aminolevallunic acid
with the help of vitamin B6.
This enzyme also
moves the reaction
from the mitochondria
to the cytoplasm.
The second enzyme,
aminolevallunic acid dehydratase,
converts aminolevallunic
acid to porphobilinogen.
This eventually will come
down the line and this
porphobilogen will be
converted to protoporphyrin and
transported back into the
mitochondria. My apologies.
At this point, ferroketolase
will come along and
be the final aspect of
this pathway, attaching
iron, which we see here,
to our protoporphyrin. And
these three key enzymes
are the usual major
suspects of why there will
be a cytoplastic anemia.
So again, the pathophysiology
is actually defective
protoporphyrin synthesis.
The issue still relies on
making heme, but it's no
longer an issue of iron.
And there are a few
different causes.
It could be a
congenital defect.
Usually the most common
defect is in aminolevallunic
acid synthase, which
is an X-linked trait.
Acquired causes
include alcoholism,
which poisons the
mitochondria, lead,
which inhibits ALAD
and ferroketolase,
and also vitamin B6 deficiency,
which again is needed
for aminolevallunic acid
synthase. and this is commonly
seen as a side effect of
tuberculosis treatment,
so with the antibiotic
isoniazid. So again, if you
hear the buzzwords, tuberculosis
patients, cyroblastic
anemia, start thinking
maybe this is B6 deficiency.
So lead poisoning is another
kind of cause of cyroblastic
anemia, but it's also a
little bit more specific.
So lead will inhibit two
different aspects of the
pathway. So it inhibits
ferroketolase and aminolabalunic
acid dehydratase, which is
the last step and second
step. We're going to see a
decrease in heme synthesis and
an increase in red blood
cell protoporphyrin. Again,
we can make the protoporphyrin,
but it can't be attached
to the iron because
that's the last step where
ferroketolase comes into play.
It also inhibits ribosomal
RNA degradation, which
causes basophilic stippling.
Essentially, lead denatures
ribonuclease, which
helps break down ribosomes.
If we can't break down
our ribosomes, you'll have
the ribosomal RNA remain
in the cells, which causes
basophilic stippling.
Don't worry too much
about the pathophys behind
why the basophilic stippling
occurs, but I always
like to just include it
for completion's sake.
so the symptoms of lead
poisoning is actually
pretty nice with this mnemonic
lead so it starts with
lead lines on the gingivate
and the metiphysis
of the long bones could you
could have encephalopathy
which is just confusion
as well as erythrocyte
basophilic stippling
which we just spoke about
you could have abdominal
colic and citeroblastic
anemia and you also have
wrist drop and foot drop
and your exposures when
you think about it usually
children in older houses i
don't know why a lot of test
questions kind of push
towards this i don't know how
many houses have lead paint
at this point but typically
if you see a clinical
vignette where the child
you know the family moved
into a house from the 1930s
1970s 60s and they're now
presenting with lead poisoning
type symptoms start
thinking about oh maybe this
is the issue and then an
adult you could think about
occupation hazards i personally
have never tried lead
but according to this
advertisement from probably like
1910 they're very yummy
so cytooblastic anemia lab
findings again our mcv is
under 80. total iron binding
capacity is going to be
low we have all the iron
we need our issues no longer
in iron depletion or iron
storage, right? Our ferritin
is going to be high,
therefore our TIBC will be
low because we're producing
less transparent. Our percent
saturation, again high,
we're in a general iron
overload state. And again,
because we're iron overloaded,
we're going to have an
increase in serum iron. And
just to reiterate this one
more time, this is not an
issue of iron. We are in
iron overload. Our issue
relies on the protoporphyrin
production. We have enough
iron to create the heme.
So for our cyderoblastic
anemia findings on bone marrow
aspirate we see ring
cyderoblasts that only appear
with prussian blue stains
and this is due to just
overall excess iron
accumulating in the perinuclear
mitochondria and you need a
prussian blue stain to see
this and again this is
only seen on bone marrow
aspirate not in a peripheral
blood smear. On blood smear
you're going to see the
basophilic stippling of the
red blood cells and this is
again due to the aggregates
of the residual ribosomes
and the ribosomal RNA.
And this is again
seen on normal right
giezma peripheral
blood smear staining.
Our final microcytic anemia
will be thalassemias.
So thalassemia is an anemia
due to a decreased synthesis
in the globin chains of
hemoglobin. We now have an
issue with the other aspect
of hemoglobin, right? We
talked about our issues with
production of heme through
protoporphyrin or maybe iron
loss and now we're talking
about our globin issues
and in a normal hemoglobin
cell you have two beta chains
and two alpha chains as
your globins and in the past
you know this was typically
an inherited mutation and
this had some evolutionary
benefit as a asymptomatic
mutation of some of these
globin chains actually he'll
protect against malaria.
Thalassemias are separated
into alpha thalassemia
and beta thalassemia, and
they're based and named
off of the globin that is
decreased in production,
right? So alpha thalassemia
will have decreased
alpha globin, and beta
thalassemia will have decreased
beta globin. And the
body will react to the
decrease in one globin
chain, usually by increasing
production of others. So
you could also see unbound
alpha and beta chains
precipitate within the red
blood cells and this is
because if we lose all of
our beta globin production
the body's going to try
and produce more alpha
globin to try and compensate
but these unbound alpha
globins actually will
precipitate and cause damage
to the cell and decrease
cell production and
lifespan you could also see
membrane alterations
increasing the risk of rupture
on your peripheral blood
smear you're going to see
target cells and this is
just essentially due to an
increase in total surface
area and a decrease in volume,
right? We have less
hemoglobin. We can produce less
hemoglobin. You're going
to see these target
cells. You also may see
nucleated red blood cells
just in an attempt for the
bone marrow to throw out
very, very immature red
blood cells to try and get
them out. And as you
can recall, our immature
erythroid precursor cells
still have their nucleus.
Our lab findings, you
typically will see a
very low MCV. If you
see a MCV less than
70, some alarm bells
should be going off in
your head that maybe
this is thalassemia.
That does not mean that it
cannot be greater than 70.
And also, your red
blood cell count
could be normal in
a mild thalassemia.
So, just very briefly,
I want to review the
hemoglobin configurations.
We have four types of
globin chains, alpha,
beta, gamma, and delta.
In a normal adult, we see
mostly HbA, which is 2
alpha, 2 beta. We see a
little bit of HbA2, which
is 2 alpha, 2 delta.
And then you could also
have hemoglobin F, which
you see a lot more in fetal
hemoglobin smears, which
is 2 alpha, 2 gamma.
All of these have
two alpha chains, the
one commonality
between all of them.
So in alpha thalassemia, the
alpha chain is the issue.
We usually see gene deletions
in alpha thalassemia,
so therefore we have a
decrease in alpha chain
production. There are four
alpha genes present on
chromosome 16, if you can
see here, kind of these four.
As the number of gene deletions
increase, the severity
of the thalassemia also
increases, and it's usually
mostly prevalent in the Asian
and African populations.
So there are four separate
types of alpha thalassemia.
The first one is minima,
one gene deletion. These
usually are asymptomatic or
silent carriers. Alpha thalassemia
minor, two gene deletions,
is usually a mild
microcytic anemia with an
increase in red blood cells. And
you can see two different
types of this type of deletion.
You could have the cyst
deletion, meaning the
deletion is lost on the same
gene, and this actually has
an increased rate of a severe
anemia in the offspring,
right, because the offspring
will receive one of these
two genes, and if it receives
the gene with no alpha
chains or alpha globin genes,
then there's a risk for a
higher rate of a severe
thalassemia. The trans deletions,
you have a gene deleted
on each copy of the gene.
The cis is usually
more common in the
Asian population,
while the trans
deletion is more
common in the African.
Three alpha chains or alpha
globin losses is hemoglobin
H disease, and this is when
you start to see excess
beta globin form the tetramers,
right? The bodies can
try and produce more beta
globin to try and account for
this drop in alpha globin,
and you're going to start
to see this precipitation of
these beta You're going to
see hemoglobin H seen on
electrophoresis, which is
just four beta globins. And
finally, you're going to see
hemoglobin BARTs, which is
no alpha globin chains. You
now have gamma tetromers
form in utero, right? Because
when we produce our HBF in
utero, we no longer have
alpha chains, so we're
going to have our four gamma
chains. This, unfortunately,
is very sad. It is incompatible
with life, and HBBARTs is
seen on electrophoresis.
So beta thalassemia
is now issues
with the beta chain.
Our beta chain is
not produced due
to gene mutations.
This is in contrast
to the gene deletions
that we see in
alpha thalassemia.
This results in an
absent beta chain or
diminished beta chain,
which are denoted by the B
sub 0 or B sub plus in
the beta globin chain.
Again, we have two genes
present of the beta globin
on chromosome 11, and
again similarly to alpha
thalassemia as we increase
the number of deletions the
severity of thalassemia
increases and we see the
prevalence more in mediterranean
and african populations
beta thalassemia minor
is the milder form you
usually have a mutation
on one gene it's usually
asymptomatic with increased
red blood cell counts and
it's due to decreased
beta globin you could see
some delta globin
produced creating the hba2
hemoglobin but this again
doesn't really cause any severe
issues, but you will
see an increase in HbA2.
These individuals, for the most
part, are okay
and can live life.
Beta thalassemia intermedia
is a variable anemia, and
then finally beta thalassemia
major, my apologies, is
a mutation on both genes.
There's no beta globin chains,
so you're going to see a
drastic increase in HbA2
with the delta
globin and the gamma
globin with HbF being produced.
So in beta thalassemia major,
you're going to see both
these increases in HbA2
and HbF. However, it won't
appear right away from
birth. HbF, because we're not
using beta globins, are
actually protective for the
first few months of their
lives. But you will eventually
see the unpaired alpha
chains precipitate and damage
red blood cell membranes,
and you also see ineffective
collective erythropoiesis
and extravascular hemolysis,
which is the removal of
red blood cells by the
spleen because they are just
not being transferred well.
You're also going to see
erythroid hyperplasia, so
that's expansion of red
blood cell production into
the skull and the facial
bones. The bone marrow
is scrambling to try and
produce more red blood cells
because the hemoglobin
really can't be produced
well, so it's going to
go into any bone it can.
You're going to see this
crew cut and chipmunk facies,
and here's your crew cut
and here's your chipmunk
facies, You're also going
to see extramedullary
hematopoiesis. So again,
we're going to start
producing red blood cells
in the spleen and the liver.
You also have a
risk of aplastic
crisis with paravirus anemia.
Your peripheral blood
smear, again, you're
going to see a microcytic
hypochromic red
blood cells with target
cells and nucleated
or very, very immature
red blood cells.
Nucleated, again, is just
another term for very
young red blood cells because
remember, they lose their
nucleus as they develop
in the bone marrow. and
treatment is usually
chronic red blood cell
transfusions iron chelations
and splenectomy but this is
a very severe disease
here's your electrophoresis
i'm not going to go over
each of these but if you
have any specific questions
please feel free to reach
out and here's a simple
algorithm so it is now
time for some questions i'm
going to go through each
of them and then we'll
talk about them together.
So question one,
a 57-year-old male presents
to the ED after being
found unresponsive outside
a liquor store. According
to previous records, this
has happened at least
20 times. He's laying on
the hospital bed. He has
IV fluid administration,
potassium repletion.
They're all initiated. His
vitals seem fairly normal.
His labs reveal an increase
in AST, ALT, and GGT,
which are all markers
for alcohol *****. His
hemoglobin is low, and his
MCV is microcytic, so what do
we think we should be
seeing on a peripheral blood
smear? Could we see
hypersegmented neutrophils?
Probably not.
That's going to be
seen more in
macrocytic anemias.
Ring cytoarblasts,
okay, I'm actually thinking
this is a cytoarblastic
anemia, right? This
could be alcohol *****.
So maybe this is,
you know, I know ring
cytoblasts are an issue
in cytoblastic anemia.
Are we going to see
macrocytes? I don't
think so. Are we going
to see target cells?
Probably not. That actually
has more to do with
thalassemias. So now
we're left with basophilic
stippling and ring
cytoblasts. Both are
things seen in cytoblastic
anemia. However,
we're asking about
peripheral blood smear here.
We see ring cytoroblasts
on bone marrow
aspirate. So our
correct answer is
going to be D,
basophilic stippling.
So this question actually
has two correct answers.
So we're going to go through
it. Seven-year-old boy
is brought to the clinic
by his mother, recently
immigrated from Italy,
concerned because she's had a
blood disorder, wants to
make sure her son is okay.
The father is healthy. The
mother sometimes suffers
from mild fatigue, yellowing
of the eyes, which are
signs of extravascular
hemolysis, actually. Physical
exam's fine. CBC shows a
low hemoglobin and a low
MCV. What type of hemoglobin
is most likely to be
increased in this boy's
electrophoresis? So, okay, he's
Italian. The mom has some
signs of, like, fatigue,
anemia, maybe a little
jaundice. I'm thinking maybe
this is the thalassemia,
right? So what hemoglobins
are increased? We have a
decrease in hemoglobin B,
right?
So are we going to see an
increase in hemoglobin A,
which has two alpha and two
beta chains? Probably not.
Will I see an increase with
hemoglobin F and hemoglobin A2?
Probably. So let's keep those
open. How about hemoglobin
S? No, you'll learn that's
in sickle cell disease
and hemoglobin C. again no
you're going to see that's
in HBC disease. So our two
correct answers again are
B and C hemoglobin F
and hemoglobin A2 will
be increased. Again
we're losing our beta
globins so we're going
to go to our gamma chains
for hemoglobin F and
our delta chains for
hemoglobin A2 that combine
with hemoglobin A's.
Question 3. 59-year-old
female, 20-year history of
rheumatoid arthritis,
Hashimoto's, comes to the clinic
for recent exacerbations
of her arthritis and also
now new-onset fatigue. She
doesn't take her medications
consistently. Her physical
exam is fairly unremarkable,
but the CBC shows anemia.
Her MCV is low, and
her ESR, which is an acute
inflammatory marker is 92,
which is very elevated. You
order an iron study, which
lab findings will you
most likely find? So first
off, what do we think this
is? It's most likely anemia
of chronic disease, right?
So in anemia of chronic
disease, we're going to see
an increase in ferritin.
Our TIBC should be
decreased, right? Because
our ferritin and TIBC
usually go opposites. our
CRM iron is going to be
decreased because we're
trying to keep all of
it in the bone marrow,
and the percent saturation
is also going to
be decreased because,
again, we're losing our
CRM iron and we're
increasing our TIPC, and
this percent saturation
is CRM iron over TIPC.
And if you really
want to think about it
and play the game, you
can't have an increase
and decrease of
ferritin in the same
answer. So this answer
choice is going to be
C, an increase in
ferritin. Again, we're
driving all of the
iron into our stores.
Question four, a 67-year
-old male presents to your
office because he's been
feeling fatigued, lost 15
pounds in the last three
months, 30-pack-year ******,
drinks regularly. He's
noticed ****** streaks in a
stool. On physical exam, you
note pale conjunctiva. The
CBC shows a low hemoglobin
and a microcytic anemia.
What type of anemia is he
most likely experiencing?
Okay, so I need to read
through this, right? We
spoke about earlier, in
elderly individuals, a
very common sign of blood
loss could be, you know,
through the GI system.
We see a loss of weight,
15 pounds in three
months, which is a
little bit alarming,
chronic ******, chronic
drinker we could be thinking
that maybe this is some
form of colon cancer again
colon cancer and blood
loss is actually one of the
driving causes of answer
c iron deficiency anemia
and anemia of chronic
disease they really
want to present with
these symptoms you'd want
to think someone who's
more of a individual
with you know chronic
illness or infection
Cytoroblastic anemia,
you could make the kind
of claim for drinks
alcohol regularly, right?
But when you read the ******
streaks, pale conjunctiva,
you kind of push you
more towards blood loss.
Thalassemia doesn't
really present very
similar here, right?
Especially in a 67-year
-old male, would this
be the first time they
present with thalassemia?
Probably not.
Lead poisoning,
you know, the vignette
doesn't describe
any form of like
potential exposure,
so I kind of stay
away from that.
So, our last question,
question 5, we have an 8
-year-old boy who was
adopted from China two
years ago, brought into
the office by his adopted
mother for complaints of
fatigue, abdominal pain,
and bouts of confusion.
His teacher has
confirmed these same concerns
that the mothers had.
There's no available
history in the
patient's birth
mother or father.
Physical exam shows
lines on the gingiva.
The CBC is 72, MCV, and
the iron study is the
following. We have high
serum iron, high ferritin,
TIBC is low, and percent
saturation is high.
What's the most
likely contributing
factor to this presentation?
First thing you should
probably do here is
kind of identify what's
going on with the
kid. All right, so
we kind of have these
symptoms, fatigue,
abdominal pain, confusion.
All right, that doesn't really,
you know, scream at anything.
Lines on the gingiva could
be leading us towards a
certain type of anemia.
I'm not going to talk about
it right now just to kind
of continue to work it.
Even if you don't recognize
lines on the gingiva,
we can use our kind of
inference to look further.
So we look at iron, right?
Are serum iron's high?
Okay, that doesn't
usually happen in iron
deficiency anemia or
anemia of chronic disease.
So that kind of
eliminates answer E.
And that also kind of
eliminates answer C, right?
Because nutritional
insufficiency is iron
deficiency. and chronic
underlying inflammatory
state. It's usually
anemia of chronic disease.
Increased ferritin
can be, you know,
iron deficiency anemia.
Actually, my apologies.
Increased ferritin can
be anemia of chronic
disease, but we've already
ruled that out because
our serum iron is high.
TIBC is low, again, partially
because ferritin is high.
Percent saturation is high.
Okay, so now we're
between A, B, and D.
So for A, genetic condition
affecting alpha globin
chain via an error in
the promoter sequence.
Okay, I think they're talking
about alpha thalassemia
here, but the explanation
here is actually wrong, an
error in the promoter
sequence. If you can remember,
alpha thalassemia is
due to a gene deletion,
not errors in the
promoter sequence.
Beta thalassemia is due to
errors in the
promoter sequence.
So A and B are actually
flipped explanations
of one another. And
additionally, when
you look at kind
of these presenting
symptoms, abdominal
pain, confusion, right?
Maybe this individual
also has some wrist
drop. They have the lead
lines on the gingiva.
This should be screaming
lead poisoning.
Okay, but what's, you know,
an underlying cause or risk
factor? How about a recent
move to a home built in
the 1920s, right? maybe this
individual this child had
some lead chips and thought
they were delicious and
now has some lead poisoning
so this kind of concludes
the lecture here's just a
little bit of a flow chart
more a little bit more
clinically oriented but a good
read and here's just kind
of a breakdown of what we've
learned and also where we're
going here are my references
and finally here's my
lecture feedback form please
guys if you have some time
I know you're all busy I
I would love some feedback,
whether it's good or bad.
Please give me some feedback.
This is my first time
making a lecture, so any
feedback would be greatly
supported. Thank you all,
I hope you're all doing
well. Happy studying, good
luck with your future comps,
and enjoy the next part
of the lecture, part two.